this is what the future of hyper
intelligence looks like most people no
longer own cars instead artificial
intelligence operates fully electric
Network self-driving Vehicles as a
result air pollution and traffic
congestion plummet across the planet
self-navigating aerial drones are on the
front lines for Disaster Response and
search and rescue missions most people
live and work side by side with
self-aware Androids these AI companions
boost productivity and liberate humans
from tedious tasks completely
revolutionizing Modern Life
[Music]
feel like I'm in a superhero movie today
scientists are blazing a trail to this
very future the fact that we're enabling
the system to make its own decisions I
don't even know where to begin with that
I want to know what breakthroughs are
being made it's talking and it's having
this Dynamic conversation with you
that's the Wonder machines can be
self-aware in ways that we can't that
will Forge the future too oh my gosh
it's looking at me
hyper intelligence
[Music]
foreign
Bigler as an engineer and neuroscientist
in training I'm obsessed with artificial
intelligence
as a kid my father took me to Tech and
Robotics trade shows where I became
dazzled by science every year the
inventions were smarter and smarter
artificial intelligence has come a very
long way in the last couple of years
most AI Technologies are programmed to
think for themselves to learn from
examples kind of like simulating human
intelligence in a way that it learns
from past experience
but how does AI actually work
in the future will AI achieve human
traits like emotion Consciousness or
even Free Will and how will humans and
robots work together
today the clearest road to the future is
the self-driving car
unlike a regular car which is just a
machine a self-driving car is a robot
that can make decisions
in the future will every car on the road
become driverless
to find out I've come to a hotbed of
self-driving car research Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania every single person has
started to have conversations about
self-driving cars because essentially
they're the future
but in order to understand it we have to
look under the hood making decisions on
the Fly even simple ones like these does
not come easy for computers
to discover the inner workings I'm
meeting a true Pioneer in the field
please get it thank you Dr Raj Rajkumar
of Carnegie Mellon University
Carnegie Mellon is the birthplace of
self-driving car technology thanks in
large part to the work of Raj and his
colleagues they've been the leading
innovators in this field for more than
25 years
so how does his self-driving car make
decisions to safely navigate the world
like a human driver
um should we get started yes we can
since Raj is distracted by our
conversation for safety reasons the
state of Pennsylvania requires another
driver in the front seat to monitor the
road
this is so cool I'm nervous but excited
with the longest you've ever driven a
vehicle autonomously oh we have gone
hundreds of miles awesome
I'm going to go Auto by pressing this
button
oh my gosh
it really is driving itself
While most self-driving cars are built
from the ground up Raj just bought a
regular used car and hacked it with
powerful onboard computer systems making
it more adaptable than other regular
cars
we installed a bunch of sensors in them
it is able to shift the transmission
gear it is able to turn the steering
wheel apply the brake pedal and the gas
panel it's really a software that runs
on the computers that makes this
capability really practical and there
are some very key fundamental artificial
intelligence layers that tries to mimic
what we humans do
to mimic human decision making most
self-driving cars use a combination of
cameras and advanced radar to see their
surroundings the AI software Compares
external objects to an internal 3D map
of streets signs and transportation
infrastructure the map is something that
is static in nature traffic and people
and objects are dynamic in nature the
dynamic information it figures out on
the Fly
comprehending Dynamic information allows
it to understand where it is heading
objectively in space and react to
changes and traffic signals
aha it recognizes the stop sign yes
excuse me a pedestrians we definitely
should not be honest with that person
the AI challenge to make a vehicle drive
itself is not an easy task
safety is priority number one and party
number two and number three as well
but what happens when the AI system
doesn't understand specific objects in
its surroundings
a pedestrian in Tempe Arizona was killed
last night by a self-driving taxi it's
believed to be the first fatality caused
by an autonomous vehicle this tragic
accident happened because a self-driving
vehicle didn't recognize something in
its environment
a jaywalker in the future Advanced
self-driving cars will have to make life
and death decisions on the fly if
avoiding the jaywalker means crashing
head-on with another car potentially
killing the driver what should it choose
how will scientists address Monumental
problems like these
the first wave of artificially
intelligent robots were programmed by
Engineers with static sets of rules to
achieve their goals these rules are
called algorithms but not all rules work
in all situations this approach is very
inflexible requiring new programming to
accomplish even the smallest changes in
any given task
a new approach called machine learning
has changed everything with machine
learning computers can absorb and use
information from their interactions with
the world to rewrite their own
programming becoming Smarter on their
own
yeah
to see machine learning in action I'm
meeting another Carnegie Mellon team at
an abandoned Coal Mine Dr Matt Travers
leads a group that won a challenging
Subterranean navigation competition held
by the department of defense's research
agency DARPA
they're affectionately known as R1 R2
and R stands for robot
these robot twins are designed for
search and rescue missions too dangerous
for humans and unlike the self-driving
car they operate without a map
to achieve this they have to learn to
identify every single object they
encounter on the Fly
they are programmed to go out and
actually act fully autonomously and they
will be making 100 of their own
decisions so they're recognizing objects
they're making the decision of where to
go next where to explore
to see this in action the R2 robot is
starting on a simulated search and
rescue mission to find a stranded human
dummy in the mine
imagine having a map of a collapsed mine
before you sent a team of people to go
rescue someone in that mine right like
it's a game changer
how the robot discerns elements in this
environment parallels how an infant
learns about her environment a
three-month-old uses her senses to
cognitively map out her environment and
learn to recognize her parents she
ultimately uses this map to interact
with everything in her world
just like this robot
okay so we ready to roll
artificial intelligence makes this
learning curve possible but how does it
create its own map and identify a human
on its own and without an internal
mapping system like the internet
test engineer Steve willitz shows me how
the R2 robot can detect a surrounded
person
when you're in a search and rescue
scenario that's kind of situation where
you'd want to deploy one of these as it
explores and maps The Cave it drops
devices called signal repeaters to
create a Wi-Fi network Trail it drops
those just like breadcrumbs along the
path using this network the robot sends
data back to home base to create a map
at the same time the robot must look at
every single object to identify the
stranded human so the lidar system is
giving a full laser scan
lidar stands for light detection and
ranging
similar to its cousin radar which uses
radio waves lidar systems send out laser
pulses of light and calculates the time
it takes to hit a solid object and
bounce back
this process creates a 3D representation
of the objects in the environment which
the onboard computer can then identify
this process is similar to how the eye
feeds visual data to the brain which
then recognizes the objects by tapping
into our pre-existing knowledge of what
things look like
fully understanding its environment R2
can then make better decisions about
where to go and where not to go
what are robots doing right now is
exploring
so the robot came to a junction and off
to the left it could see that it
couldn't get past right so it saw the
opening to the right and that's where it
went
[Music]
foreign it kind of looks like it's
making decisions about whether or not to
climb over these planks and obstacles
all up in this area right that's exactly
what it's doing at this point just like
a baby R2 learns through trial and error
it's like a little dog wagging its tail
but there's no one here to rescue so it
moves on
as R2 continues to map out the mine
oh my God
a human it stumbles upon its intended
target
that is Randy rescue Randy
hello rescue Randy
scared me
with the discovery of rescue Randy the
R2 robot can not only alert emergency
Personnel but also give them a map on
how to find him
that is incredible it knows what it's
doing
these incredible rescue robots are
clearly Paving the path to the future of
hyper-intelligence
in the future autonomous exploration
Vehicles perform search and rescue
missions in every conceivable disaster
Zone even in Avalanches atop Mount
Everest incredibly intelligent off-road
vehicles are also mapping deep cave
systems previously unknown to science
discovering a vast supply of rare Earth
elements essential for modern technology
artificial intelligence will clearly
save human lives in the future but
there's a lot of terrain on Earth that's
too difficult to navigate on wheels how
will intelligent robots make their way
over rainforest bodies of water
or even mountaintops
in Philadelphia Jason darinik of xn
Technologies is working to overcome this
problem
what we focus on is autonomous aerial
robotics to enable drones to safely
navigate in unknown or unexplored spaces
Jason's team has built the first
industrial drone that can fly itself
and map their environment as they go we
focus on all aspects of autonomy which
includes perception orientation of
during flight motion planning and then
finally control but going from two
Dimensions to three dimensions requires
an increase in artificial intelligence
processing
the mission for their drone is to fly
independently through a
three-dimensional path from one end of
the warehouse to the other
starting mission three two one
now to mess with its computer mind
Jason's team places new and unexpected
obstacles in its path
will the Drone recognize these
unexpected changes will it get lost
will it crash
essentially we have a gimbled lidar
system that allows the vehicle to paint
a full 360 sphere around it in order to
sense its environment
like the robot in the mine this aerial
robot uses lidar to see
it actually generates a voxelized
representation of the space which you
see here and each one of these cubes in
the space it's trying to determine
whether that cube is occupied or whether
it's free space
[Music]
of where to go based on its visual input
kind of like us humans
incredibly the Drone recognizes the
white boards and flies around them
one of the things about this system that
make it particularly special is that
it's actually being used in the real
world to keep people out of Harm's Way
[Applause]
they're already at work in hazardous
Industries like mining construction and
oil exploration they safely conduct
inspections in dangerous locations and
create detailed maps of rough Terrain
from a technological perspective the
fact that we're able to do everything
that we're doing on board self-contained
and enabling the system to make its own
decisions
I don't even know where to begin with
that
self-flying robots like these will
revolutionize search and rescue and
Disaster Response
they could also transform how packages
are delivered but there are limits to
what large single drones can do more
complex tasks will require teams of
small Nimble autonomous robots
Dr Vijay Kumar at the University of
Pennsylvania is working with swarms of
drones to perform tasks like play music
or build structures cooperatively
he's also developing Technologies to
tackle some very big problems including
world hunger in a couple of decades
we'll have over 9 billion people to feed
on this planet of course that's a big
challenge to take on a task this big
he's building an army of small flying
robots with the ability to synchronize
we think about technologies that can be
mounted on small flying robots that can
then be directed in different ways like
a flock of birds reacting to a predator
or a school of fish you have a
coordination collaboration and it all
happens very organically using AI to get
robots to work as a coordinated
Collective group is a daunting task
three five years ago most of our robots
relied on GPS like sensors today we have
the equivalent of smartphones embedded
in our robots and they sense how fast
they're going by just looking at the
world integrating that with the inertial
measurement unit information and then
getting an estimate of where they are in
the world and how fast they're traveling
This I Gotta See and I'm gonna check it
out virtually as a robot
I'm at UPenn remotely in Vijay Kumar's
lab
sample my surroundings
oh I hit something hello hi vijay's
Apprentice Dinesh takur is my guide
today we are going to show robots
playing in a formation great can we see
how that works sure yeah the first step
Dinesh takes in coordinating the drones
is to provide them with a common point
of reference in this case a visual tag
similar to a basic QR code
[Music]
using only the onboard camera these
drones reference the code on the tag and
visualize where they are in space
using sophisticated bio-inspired
algorithms the drones then figure out
where each other drone is within the
collective swarm
these drones are communicating with one
another right yeah right now they're
communicating over Wi-Fi so cool
future versions of these drones will
create their own localized wireless
network to communicate but for now this
swarm is a proof of concept you've
defined a formation and then they're
assuming that formation yeah I just say
I want to form a line and the drones
themselves figure out where they should
go once they figure out where they are
in relationship to each other they can
then work together to accomplish a
shared goal like ants working as a
collective entity once they can
coordinate between each other we can
send them out and doing specific
missions that's really cool
swarms of flying robots have their
advantages unlike a single drone
self-coordinating swarms can perform
complex operations like mapping much
faster by working in parallel and
combining their data and losing one
drone in a swarm doesn't Doom the whole
operation
[Music]
the Jay imagines employing his Advanced
swarm technology to work on farms this
Precision agriculture will help feed the
world's growing population we'd like
robots to be able to roam farms and be
able to provide precise information
about individual plants that then could
be used to increase the efficiency of
food production that would be a huge
impact in a world
this is our duty as responsible citizens
and as responsible Engineers the
high-flying approach towards resolving
the problems of the future is definitely
a path
in the future artificial intelligence
coordinates flocks of drones to protect
the environment and boost the food
supply
to combat the negative effects of
climate change on agricultural crops
robotic bees assist with pollination in
Orchards and on farms making them more
sustainable and productive
fish-shaped underwater robots
automatically deploy at the first sight
of an oil spill these drones create a
barricade to rapidly contain spills
saving marine life and oceans across the
world
modern society has a long history of
building robots to do work that's
dangerous difficult or too repetitive
for humans AI is poised to automate all
kinds of tedious work ranging from
factory work to taxi driving to customer
service
while some are worried that smart robots
will replace human labor that's not
necessarily the case as a sector
artificial intelligence is expected to
generate 58 million new types of jobs in
just a few years so what will the future
of human robot interaction mean for our
work and livelihoods
I'm at the Massachusetts Institute of
Technology to meet Dr Julie Shaw she's
leading groundbreaking research in human
robot collaboration my lab Works to
develop robots that are effective
teammates with people Julie and her team
are creating software that helps robots
learn from humans even giving them
insight into different human behaviors
by being aware of real people robots can
directly work and interact with them how
do you teach these robots or machines to
do these human-like tasks the first step
as it would be for any person the first
thing they do is become immersed in the
environment and observe and then we need
an active learning process the robot
needs to be able to communicate or show
back to the person what it's learned we
don't want the robot to learn the direct
sequence of actions we want the robot to
learn this more General understanding
that's ultimately like our challenge but
getting a robot to grasp the bigger
picture Concept in order to understand
the basic of its task in the first place
requires a lot of observation and well
hand-holding my research is focusing on
trying to make robot programming Easier
by trying to teach robots how to do
tasks by demonstrating them Julie's
colleague Ankit Shah shows me how this
robot is learning to set a table
so this is all the silverware and the
plates the Bulls the cups and this is
the table that it has to set yes that is
correct okay
as any parent knows the first step in
helping a child to learn is to model the
desired Behavior it's the same with
machine learning
in this case the AI robot recognizes the
objects with a visual tag similar to a
QR code and for two weeks it observes
unkit setting a table so did you pick up
an item and then place it on the dinner
table that's basically what we did and
based on that the robot learns what it
means to set it in a table Dynamic tasks
like setting a table or doing laundry
are easy for humans but incredibly hard
for robots the software has difficulty
with so many variables and even subtle
changes in their environment can throw
them off one of the things which I like
to do is to actually hide some of the
objects so it's not going to see the
spoon and the reason we do this is we
want to show that the robot is robust to
some of the disturbances in the task
the robot software has learned what each
object is and where it goes now let's
see if it's learned the concept and can
think dynamically to set the table
so you can just pick up the card here we
go
I've revealed the spoon
incredibly the robot recognizes the
spoon and instantly places it next to
the Bowl
this reveals that the robot has learned
the concept and executes the right
action dynamically
in the process the software is
continuously writing and revising its
own computer code basically it's
learning
foreign
if like humans robots can grasp the
bigger picture context and not just the
mathematical tasks will AI driven robots
of the future spell the end of having to
work the key aspect is not developing AI
to replace or supplant part of the human
work but really interesting how we fit
them together as puzzle pieces people
work in teams to build cars to build
planes and robots we need to be an
effective team member it's real teamwork
as if you're in a basketball game you
have your goal right and you have to
think spatially who am I going to pass
the ball to and at what time you do that
so that everything matches up the
analogy of a basketball team is
outstanding because we actually need to
know spatially where they're going to be
and the timing is of critical importance
and so we need to develop the AI for a
robot to then work with us
one of the most difficult aspects of
creating hyper-intelligence is actually
something that even we humans sometimes
get wrong and that is anticipation
anticipating what a teammate or
co-worker might do requires
understanding of contextual information
on a much more sophisticated level and
predicting what will happen next
can robots make predictions as
accurately as we can
Abby's are industrial robot
it's giving this Abbey machine the
intelligence necessary to help it
anticipate a human co-worker's action
this is a simulated manufacturing test
that we have set up okay to simulate
some sort of task that a person or robot
could visibly work on together
for safety reasons actual human robot
interaction is at present fairly minimal
typically in a factory you would see
these guys behind a metal cage and you
wouldn't have people working with them
so what we're trying to do is make
something that a person could safely
interact with what is human enroll
to do together in this task on this task
a person is placing Fasteners in some
surface of a plane and a robot applying
like a sealant over to seal in okay can
we see it happen
sure the robot must first be able to see
and recognize the actions of his human
counterpart and adjust to the person's
every move ooh I feel like I'm in a
superhero movie so the camera is in the
room can see these lights and track your
hands so that your hand doesn't get cut
off by the robot that's right yeah so
the cameras and the lights basically
work as ice for the robot so that's how
the robot knows where I am the monitor
shows the visual representation of the
room that's inside the robot's mind
so this is what the robot might be doing
if you know I'm not in this way and the
robot's just stealing and I'm not
supposed to be here
put my hands in a robust way
by quickly understanding this Human
Action the AI software reacts
accordingly
by stopping it's important to be able to
share the workspace
building on this sense of teamwork pem's
next step is helping Abby anticipate
where he will move next based on subtle
contextual cues
so in this case the robot will not only
track which actions I've done so far but
also anticipate which portion of the
space I'm going to be using okay and
when it's planning its own motions it'll
avoid those locations so that we can
more work together together so what
you'll see now is after I place this
Bolt the robot is going to predict I'm
going to go to this one next
so what you'll see is it'll behave in a
different way so now that I place this
build the robot kind of takes a more
roundabout path that allows me and the
robot to work more closely together and
I don't have to kind of worry about it
crashing into me because I can see that
it's trying to avoid me
so similarly Linda's side replace this
Bolt
let's get a robot take some more kind of
like roundabout path yeah because you're
going to go there now slow down because
I'm close to me right
work together at the same time so not
only is the interaction more efficient
in that the robot's not spending too
much time standing still
[Music]
it's safer because the robot's not
constantly kind of almost hitting me and
also feels nicer for the person working
with the robot I really love this theme
of teamwork
programming robots to coordinate with us
and anticipate where we will move won't
only revolutionize the workplace but it
will also change society at Large
in the future the coordination of men
and machine is so Advanced that this
collaboration increases productivity and
accuracy in most Industries AI robots
now accompany surgeons in hospitals
across the globe they anticipate the
doctor's needs and hand them the
appropriate medical tool just before
it's needed
this dramatically reduces surgery times
and human error
and will artificial intelligence
actually surpass human intelligence
while some machines have exceeded human
ability in games like trivia now we come
to Watson in chess these AI systems were
designed to master just a single skill
these programs use brute force computer
processing power and specially tailored
software to beat their human opponents
to achieve the Holy Grail of
hyper-intelligence scientists must
develop systems with flexible human-like
abilities to both learn and think this
form of smarts is called artificial
general intelligence
I'm back in New York City on my own
campus at Columbia University to meet
with Dr hod Lipson hod's lab is
developing creative robots that paint
original artworks self-assembling robots
and even robots that learn about their
world without human assistance
but his ultimate goal is even more
ambitious
can a machine think about itself Can it
have free will I believe that in fact
machines can be sentient could be
self-aware in ways that we can't
as a neuroscientist I know we've only
scratched the surface of our scientific
understanding of how Consciousness Works
in humans
how could one possibly use computer code
to put this Transcendent feature into a
robot
our hypothesis is actually very simple
it is that self-awareness is nothing but
the ability to simulate oneself
to model oneself to have a self-image
the first step towards creating robotic
Consciousness is to teach the software
to build an image of its physical
mechanical self inside its computer mind
we humans take Consciousness like this
for granted even in simple moments like
understanding our own image reflected in
a mirror humans start to develop
awareness of their own emotions and
thoughts around the age of one this
helps babies understand their self-image
in their minds and it helps them to
learn about their environment and their
role in it
when a robot learns what it is it can
use that self-image
to plan new tasks
both humans and robots awareness about
the ethical self is called
proprioception
neuroscientists sometimes call this
self-awareness of our bodies a sixth
sense
we use the same test that a baby does in
his crib a baby moves around flails
around moves its arm in ways that look
random to us but they're not random and
then it touches its nose right now if it
brain predicts that it's going to feel
something and it actually feels that
that means that its self-image was
correct same thing happens with the
robot if proprioception can be developed
to the same level as humans this could
lead to robotic consciousness
hot's colleague Rob quiatkowski is the
proud parent of a brand new baby robot
that he built
and by interacting with its surroundings
it's in the process of developing its
own internal self-image so what are
these claws so these are actually feet
they're designed for walking on carpet
but as of now it doesn't really walk
it's still kind of a baby needs to learn
how the world works first what do you
mean it's still kind of a baby what does
it do
like a baby it's sending completely
random actions to each of these robot
arms and really try to get an
understanding of itself primarily it
looks like a spider that that doesn't
know how to use legs yeah I guess that's
pretty good way to put it yeah
so it will really be learning by doing
this babbling for somewhere on the order
of a day to a week it will process this
data to create an informative model of
itself and from there imagine how it
would walk and then execute that walking
in the real world
these are the first baby steps towards
developing its self-image and like a
baby it will eventually learn to walk we
know this because an earlier version of
this robot using the same technique
learned to walk after 100 hours
but walking won't by default lead to
robotic consciousness
and that's why self-awareness is so
crucial this is a robot which we've
taken to calling a self-aware robot it
is self-aware pretty much in a literal
sense that it is aware of itself its
locations in space and its Dynamics as
to how it moves okay so it kind of
understands its own movements and where
it is in space how does it do that by
leveraging this technique which has
become popular in recent years called
Deep learning deep learning is a form of
artificial intelligence that like the
human brain learns through raw data
unsupervised and without structure deep
learning gives machines the ability to
experience and process reality like us
Rob has devised an experiment to test
what this robot knows about its world
you can think of it as if you're looking
at these red cotton balls you have some
idea in space as to where they are right
now if you were to close your eyes and
try to pick them up and put them in this
cup
so obviously it's not a trivial task no
but it's not the most difficult task in
the world because we have a good
proprioception we have this good model
of yourself you know where your arm is
in space relative to other things that
you see in space
but for this robot there's a catch so
where are the cameras so there's no
camera it's none as if you were to close
your eyes you know the locations at the
start and it's picking it up and placing
it completely blind furthermore it was
not given a map or any formal
instructions the robot simply has to
feel its way through the task all right
let's see it give it a shot
first the robot learned how to use its
arm through trial and error developing a
sense of proprioception
by exploring its surroundings it
generated an internal representation of
the world and its place in it
the robot is using only its internal
image of the external world to maneuver
its arm to pick up all nine balls and
place them in the cup
I'm not sure that's something I could do
with my eyes closed
huh it's really just based off of
understanding where you are in space
yeah that's right
creating AI robots that have an internal
model of their world is an important
step towards machine self-awareness
self-awareness is sort of a similar
propriet sensitive capability but
applied to mental thinking so if they
think about thinking they think about
what they are because once you can do
that it means you can plan things into
the future
once robots become self-aware they will
need Advanced ways to communicate hit
with humans keyboards and screens are
inadequate for complex thoughts
robots will need to learn to speak and
have natural conversations
like a baby who listens to those around
her and learns to talk
laying the groundwork for this kind of
human machine interaction is pioneering
scientist Barbara gross of Harvard
University her seminal work in what's
called natural language processing
directly led to the development of voice
activated artificial intelligence you
know like Alexa or Siri
natural language processing actually
predates artificial intelligence and
started with machine translation efforts
ability for a computer system to
OK spoken dialogue with a person has
been a long-standing goal of artificial
intelligence research from its Inception
and it turns out this is a challenge
because when you speak what you say
really depends on the context in which
you say it another challenge is the
meaning of words can change depending on
how they are delivered so one example is
the contrast between saying that's
fabulous they're that's fabulous also
when we have a conversation we Mark
paragraphs at the beginning with a rise
in intonation in a fall at the end so
there's a whole way the speech signal
tells you something about the context
and something about the intended meaning
Barbara's early research led to methods
for programming computers to understand
the meaning of spoken language by using
Clues from a person's tone and context
so let's Flash Forward the speech
systems are amazing now because there
are lots of recordings of people
speaking that they can build their
systems on as a result AI has gotten
much better at understanding
still room for improvement the systems
that do exist are pretty much focused on
very narrow tasks this takes Siri and
Alexa as examples they're mostly
oriented around a single question or a
single request and they presume that
anybody will stay within the range of
behavior that the designers imagined
so researchers are turning to machine
learning by training AI with hours and
hours of human conversation they can
learn to better understand the context
of how humans Converse
future versions of this technology will
allow us to have natural conversations
with our computers
one of the things that's amazing to me
is that her Fields have succeeded so
well that there are devices out in the
world that people use every day I never
dreamed that would be the case in my
lifetime
hyper-intelligent natural language AI
will change the way we interact with our
computers and robots
but this advanced technology will never
reach its full potential as human
companions until it looks convincingly
like us
I'm in Los Angeles to meet how Lee his
company pinscreen is giving AI a human
face
they're developing cutting-edge
techniques to create hyper-realistic
digital avatars in an instant one of the
hardest things to bring to the virtual
world are humans right and specifically
faces
to create believable faces how is
relying on complex AI algorithms it's an
artificial intelligence that actually
digitizes yourself into the computer by
just looking at a single image or you
know partial information and it's not
just a 3D model static one but it's one
that can also be animated and brought to
life
other methods of generating life like
avatars need to capture multiple angles
of a faith and motion and they can take
hours to render but not pin screens
technology I can show you real quick how
this works do you want to see yeah
incredibly his software also allows him
to superimpose any face he wants in real
time so if I do this this blue face is
basically a face tracker so in real time
it's actually modeling my face in 3D so
if I move around my face the blue mask
isn't basically a three-dimensional
representation of my face wow it's kind
of like a green screen
like a Hollywood CGI film the computer
dynamically models house faith and
tracks his movement on the Fly
click on him
turn myself into Putin wow
it's basically generating the whole
thing in real time right now oh my God
Putin's talking to me right now
political leaders aren't the only thing
Hal can generate
[Music]
Audrey Hepburn
it's generating all the pixels in real
time these teeth are never seen in this
picture so it's predicting what your
teeth would end up looking like these
aren't even your teeth yeah these are
not my teeth it's actually generating oh
my goodness
Howell believes that software like this
will give a more human face to the
digital world
ultimately this will result in
friendlier looking Androids and even
virtual beings I have been hanging with
my dog for a while do you have pets I
have three toy poodles
someday we're actually going to interact
with virtual beings that are going to
assist us in our life imagine instead of
talking to a Serial Alexa you're talking
to a face right and it's the best way to
communicate is to have a face-to-face
communication an AI provides you perfect
companionship
this kind of Technology will give AI a
faith that most people can relate to are
you human or are you artificial
intelligence that is a very interesting
question I think I am human but I am
artificial intelligence
hyper-intelligent companions could Usher
in a more helpful and hopeful world
[Music]
high powered virtual beings that look
talk and even think like real humans are
commonplace these holographic assistants
take care of many aspects of daily life
ranging from fashion advice to business
consultation their faces and wardrobes
can be customized depending on their
role
when a doctor is required these virtual
assistants play the part and are always
on call armed with the latest medical
knowledge they accurately diagnose most
common diseases the same technology is
also capable of capturing the image
voice and life story of loved ones
after death these virtual friends and
family are always a part of our lives
even if Engineers can create lifelike
robots that look like humans called
Androids in order for AI to become true
companions people will need to feel
comfortable embracing these Androids
figuratively and literally
I'm outside San Diego to meet Matt
McMullen the founder of real botics
Matt is building Androids that people
will want to embrace physically
the goal is to create not only a robot
but an AI that are both appealing enough
that someone would feel like they were
actually getting to know someone not
something
once the sculpting and casting is
complete members of math
on an actual functioning robot
the faces are actually modular the face
just literally comes off yes it does the
idea is you create one robotic head and
a whole bunch of different characters
that can all run on that same heads
so all of the things that move in the
face are actuated by these magnets that
are in skin
[Music]
programmers use artificial
and advanced chat Bots for these robots
the goal is for them to have natural
conversations with their companions
blanket
yeah she's a blinker
it's looking at me hello how are you
today
I'm okay
I I'm fine I'm doing just fine how are
you
why do you ask me that
um you know because I care about your
feelings
[Music]
speech is only one aspect of human
communication facial expressions are
hugely important in social interaction
so Matt is incorporating this non-verbal
communication into his Androids
the vision system that we're working on
she'll be able to look at you and detect
your emotion by the expression on your
face by the temperature of your skin and
all these other things coming
or is key right yes exactly it looks
remarkable it's moving it's talking and
it's having this Dynamic conversation
with you that's the Wonder
I can imagine some people might walk in
here and say oh look at sex robot the
thing is to make a really impressive and
good sex robot you actually have to make
a good robot in the first place but I
think that the the longer term goals are
going to be to create these systems for
people to use in whatever way they see
fit
we're creating human-like robots that we
think can be used for a huge variety of
things for people who are lonely whether
they're old or maybe they're socially
isolated or maybe they suffer from
social anxiety Androids with a friendly
face could keep the elderly company and
monitor their health armed with
artificial intelligence these Androids
could take on other qualitative roles
I think therapy is a huge one using the
robot as a safe conduit for
communication and letting people really
open up because they don't feel like
they're being judged by something like
this yeah companion Androids like this
will Forge a future where nobody will
ever have to feel alone again
wow life like human Androids and virtual
beings have the potential to enhance
human social interactions there are
ethical concerns as well
using artificial intelligence it's
possible to hijack a person's physical
identity there is one very big problem
in the whole thing which is privacy what
if I would do something harmful to you
when you say harmful you mean
reconstruct somebody and have them say
something that would they would never
say or never do right
digital Fabrications like this are
already emerging online in what are
called Deep fakes I can go on your
website take a picture from it and then
create some content with it without your
consent
also dangerous swarms of AI driven
drones could be used in terrorist
attacks can drones be weaponized
of course they can be recognized these
scientific breakthroughs yield results
again oftentimes be used against humans
so you have to be held accountable for
what you developed and it's a moral
responsibility to think about the
broader consequences
when it comes to ethical considerations
like
feel hopeful that science technology and
human Ingenuity will find solutions to
these big problems the potential for
artificial intelligence to profoundly
improve Society to improve jobs to
improve health care to improve education
is enormous if we do it the right way
trying to build computer systems that
assist them in doing what they're doing
better technology is more likely to
provide some tools that will allow us to
become superhuman augment our
intelligence to make better decisions
and to get better insights about the
world future versions of this technology
will become even more intelligent than
us humans I believe there's no doubt
robots will exceed human capability I
mean the path is very clear whether it's
going to take 20 years or 200 years this
is maybe the most powerful technology
we've ever invented
potential of
you can ultimately probably program a
robot or or a computer to carry out your
vision
and in the right hands this technology
has the potential to radically transform
every part of daily life for the better
a true partnership with
hyper-intelligent robots with their
intentions aligned with our own will
transform Humanity for the greater good
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]